one of the things that I I know from
reading and hearing about that you
actually was connected to this project
through a mutual hairdresser actually we
I just came from the hair so on and she
was there I mean that my hair does her
left the salon to go do her hair so we
still share the same hairdresser which
was just total serendipity and New York
thing you know I was I I had been in the
salon and I saw this woman crushed to
the color station and I said to my
hairdresser is that Elaine Stritch and
he said yeah she's been a longtime
client of mine then he's like snip snip
snip he goes well you know you should be
making a documentary about her and you
know I thought hmm you know and it kind
of like thought about it and then I went
home and I youtube then I googled her
and I downloaded at liberty and
everything else I could get my hands on
and I of course became obsessed because
I had no idea you know her history in
the theater and you know the legis I
mean she just had such an enormous body
of work but she's also such a
fascinating character her personality
her talent is so unusual and singular
and everything about her life was
fascinating to me it took several months
of courtship I'd say and I think my hair
does her probably played a role in it
and that I think that he intentionally
set up our appointment so that we would
like to bump into each other the salon
over and over again but I you know I
started talking about her before I
actually approached her to people that I
knew because I wasn't sure that enough
people knew who she was and then I
thought that's the reason to make the
film it's because not enough people know
who she is you know everyone in New York
know is Elaine don't you think
absolutely i mean the more I talked
about her but I think there's a cut-off
point I think people under 40 not so
much you know maybe that if they're
watching 30 rock yeah absolutely but
still you know they don't know about her
they know that she's you know Alec
Baldwin's mother but they don't know
about her history so I started chatting
with her in the salon PA started talking
about me and
my career because by that time I had
been producing dots for six or seven
years and and I invited her to one of
them we had we had a screening at 90
second Street why before we had a
theatrical and she really enjoyed it and
then but she kept not letting me start
to film you know I'd say oh maybe I
could bring a camera to the salon or
maybe I can you had see this and she's
like oh no no no and I'd say well you
know you're just at the end of shooting
night music and wouldn't that be
fantastic to capture she's like oh no
and she was just so belligerent about it
and she'd say look you know when I get
some spare time I'll give you a call but
otherwise you know let's let's put the
inside her voice it's kyra but but so
finally her music director rob bowman
was seated next to me at dinner party
given by the salon owner who's a friend
of mine and ants out Rob and I became
very chummy and and so he said so you're
trying to make are you the one that's
going to make a film about Elaine and I
said well god only knows we've I've been
you know asking her for about four
months and I don't think it's gonna
happen between you and me and he said
why not and I said just because she
keeps putting me off and telling me yes
and putting me off and he said oh you
know she'll get over that and a week
later she called me at 2am and left me a
voicemail on my work number and she said
look Jimmy me whatever your name is I
really want to get on with this with
this film idea what's the deal you know
can we start shooting now you know and
so suddenly the door was open and we'd
always the door open though you were
everywhere I mean it was such intimate
access you saw her at her weakest how
most vulnerable she kind of sauces
things out and it's very touch and go
and then suddenly she just grabs you and
you're in here that what I read and
that's we just started having a
relationship you know like a friendship
and she's got to know my cameraman and
all by their first name and and we just
started spending time together and I was
going through incredible crises in my
own life my family my brother my
boyfriend everything was sort of falling
down around me and she would ask me so
what's going on with you and she was
very interested to know she's fascinated
by people their private life everything
and so I just kind of like
and um and we became closer and closer
and then she wanted us around all the
time she would call me up at one in the
morning and say listen I'm feeling a
little chatty if you got that camera
around wow so she would so you were on
call yeah I mean I couldn't always get a
cameraman and I could not you know I
whenever we could I had three guys on my
speed dial and I would just say hey do
you have a camera can you meet me the
car line 45 minutes to us was this was
over how long a period of time about a
year and a half did she have final say
of what to put in and what to take out
um no she did not I sister Robin a very
different movie if that were the case
did so did you you were with her when
she has seen this obviously yeah well
hotel tells i'm she she the first time I
showed it to her we were sitting you
know we hunt when you hang out with her
at the Carlile there's only that bed
there's really nowhere else to sit in
that room because the little love seat
has a hundred pillows on it you know and
and every other every other seat has
either doesn't really work or it's
covered with books so you have to kind
of hang out on her bed with her and we
were watching the rough cut on my laptop
you know on our laps like this and she
was like oh my god what's going to
happen now oh my god yeah and I said you
know what happens everything's fine you
go to the hospital you'll find I don't
know if I can watch this and then but it
was interesting because she watched
herself like she was in third person and
and and six months earlier I had showed
her a fundraising teaser that I made
that she loved and she kept saying oh my
god I look adorable in every scene and
and then I showed her this and she was
like I've never seen anything like it
she said I don't even know what to think
and I said well what were you interested
in it as a movie and she said well yes
and and then she said I think it's
really enjoy she said I've never seen
anything like this so I thought we were
on the right track and then when I
locked picture a couple months later we
got into Tribeca and I figure I better
show her the picture lock and so you
know we had a small i rented a small
theater and we showed it i'm sorry i
didn't rent in my producer got it
donated to us at nyu and we screened it
for a small audience and I didn't tell
them that she would be there because I
thought we'd surreptitiously like sneak
her into the back of the
room so she could get the audience
reaction you know but of course she
walks into the room and the credits open
and she goes hello gang and everyone
went like and then and then I think they
all sort of checked themselves because
it was such an intimate movie and I
don't think they were prepared to be you
know overseen by the lady so I think
that I think the responses were a little
bit more subdued than that it would have
been had she not been there and she was
sort of nervous about it and after
everybody left she sort of started
giving me this litany of things that
could have been better and more funny
and more costumes and you know it was it
was really interesting I mean listen
this is how I became a director I said
to Elaine we're going to hire a really
fancy director and that's going to help
us raise the funds for the movie and you
know someone with brilliant expertise
because the I'd only been a producer at
that stage and I was just out and I felt
like I was out in the field gathering
information and and she said why don't
you do it and I said well because I
don't have I mean I'm not a director of
any experience you know and she said
well I'm not gonna meet another person I
don't I don't want to meet another
person why why don't you I want you to
do it and I said okay and I was pretty
naively because I think that when you're
producing and directing a film about
Elaine you have no idea what you're
bargaining for when you frightened um
you know what I wasn't I was sort of
relieved because by that time we'd
already done six weeks of shooting and I
thought how am I going to explain to
someone what it's like to step into this
position and deal with all of that stuff
that you have to get through before you
actually get to do what you want to do
you know now when you began did you know
that she was going to be eventually
leaving and going home to two dro know
so that came up in the course of your
fab solutely the only thing I did know
going into it was that she had a series
of shows planned at the Carlile just
like she always does and that they were
invited to go other places like Detroit
in LA and and that she had just um
donated her archive to the stella adler
studio and they had invited her to come
her room right and so I I was the thing
that I thought was going to be the
the spine in this amazing thing and it
kind of was was her unpacking the
archives that she hadn't seen in 30
years would we say that her music
director is a saint Oh beyond rob bowman
is beyond he gets like five stars on the
boy scout thing he's amazing amazing guy
the great thing about Rob is he's an
amazing communicator you know and if
they were going to do rehearsals or if
they were going to do something and he
would just text me and say you know
Elaine's thinking about this the lanes
thinking about that and by that time he
was very friendly with myself and my
cameraman and Julie keys or other close
friend you know it's kind of keeping
tabs on everything and and the three of
us have become very close as well
because you sort of you know when you've
survived the friendship of Elaine
Stritch there's like this camaraderie
that develops that you know in a bit
absolutely